but first it's a story we're still all
talking about as will smith continues to
face backlash for slapping chris rock
during sunday night's oscars co-host amy
schumer broke her silence taking to
instagram admitting she's stunned and
sad amy writes in part
still triggered and traumatized i love
my friend chris rock and believe he
handled it like a pro stayed up there
and gave an oscar to his friend quest
love and the whole thing was so
disturbing so much pain in will smith
amy's fellow co-host wanda sykes also
shared how the moment made her feel
during an appearance on the ellen
degeneres show take a look
and i just felt so
awful for my my friend you know chris
and uh
and it was it was sickening it was
absolutely i physically
felt ill and i'm still a little
traumatized
me too
meanwhile thomas hayden church called
into sirius xm's debatable and shared
his harsh take on how will should be
punished
what he did
despite how he tried
to scramble for an explanation and
and quite frankly
uh i think a pretty pathetic excuse
that he was doing it out of love out of
protection
for jada
i mean in my mind
and and and i don't know if it's ever
going to be put to a vote with the
academy it's you know obviously a very
big and diverse
organization i think that will smith
should be banned from the oscars for the
rest of his life
i think
he
should have his academy membership
stripped
but i do not
i don't think he should have the oscar
taken from him
steve harvey also weighed in on the
subject matter of chris rock's joke
which as we know pokes fun at jada
pinkett smith's bald head which is a
result of alopecia during a recent
discussion on his steve harvey morning
show steve said will completely
overreacted as he felt the joke did not
warrant that type of response
i understand that defending the honor of
your wife i'm that dude but you don't
have to do something
for that he didn't do that that joke was
not worthy of of of the reaction if he
was gonna have a reaction i think that
will should have done the man thing
would step to him afterwards
in that press room and if he wants to
slap chris then he could have slapped
chris in the press room and seeing how
it went
but see he laughed at the joke until he
saw jada's reaction now wheels it not
but now let me tell you something that's
a hollywood move now to go up there on
national tv slap another black man turn
around your back and walk off because
you know he can't do nothing
and in other news chris rock returns to
the stage in boston tonight as he kicks
off his ego death world tour ticket
sales have skyrocketed as you can guess
uh since the oscars incident sangeeta
oh what do you think we had the raw
emotions on monday when you and i had
that conversation sunday night we felt
and now it's like all the celebrities
have come out and talking about it and i
go back to that night
and the first question i was running
around and i said did everyone give him
a standing ovation when he was doing his
speech i wanted to see people's reaction
afterwards after the math i knew you
know people said they should have taken
them out or you know people should have
reacted it's hard when you're in that
situation how to react right people just
did what they knew uh you know when i
think about what um jim carrey said you
know there were spineless that night and
you know there's not that much respect
for the for hollywood anymore and i
think back to that moment and now people
are responding outside of the box
knowing what social media is saying and
saying yeah the slap and everyone agrees
this lap was wrong do you think he
should not be invited back to the oscars
i don't know i think
listen the oscars has been
um kind of like
fighting with the idea of low ratings
for a very long time yeah they want to
have really high ratings next time
have them on with chris right like we
talk about this i don't i don't know if
it's the right thing to do uh if it's
the wrong thing to do but if they want
those people watching that's like the
easy get for people to see what you know
yeah i mean chris
chris it's exciting to actually see what
chris is going to do
with his stand-up when it comes to this
like his very first performance out of
this
obviously going to talk about it
obviously has things he's going to say i
don't know i don't know if he's going to
acknowledge it and i hope he does
because i was on twitter with his
brother tony rock and one of the
questions he does this thing a ritual
when he answers question and one of them
was do you approve of the apology and he
said no
so his brother you know he's he's kind
of talking on his side so does he bring
it up or not maybe he still wants to
press charges and if he does he cannot
speak about it tonight right so let's
see what happens i love the fact that
his ticket sales have gone up because
people you know want to see this and see
what he has to say but uh at the end of
day i think chris rock should be doing
the oscars but i i think um will smith
should not be invited to the oscars
after that you know we have a lot of
people agreeing with you here people
saying that that will should be banned
someone here says not not jada but will
yeah yeah this is going to go on for a
while there's a lot to talk about there
for sure